we're gonna talk about the major
benefits of something called a tapa
genie and exactly what a tapa G really
is okay so in the cell you have
something called the lysosome and
lysosome is like the garbage disposal
it's like the recycler which takes all
the damaged parts and breaks it down has
all these enzymes and then it spits it
out as free fatty acids and amino acids
which are the building blocks to make
body tissue at this point they're pushed
out to different parts of the body in
which you have cellular remodeling so
just imagine in your house you have a
garbage disposal you put your garbage in
there and let's say it comes out as
great wood nails raw material to then
build your new kitchen your new bathroom
and other rooms in your house well
that's exactly what a top as he is which
it takes garbage and makes it into new
good raw material so you can then build
new cells so it's very anti aging it's
very good to protect the brain cells to
regrow new brain cells and nerve cells
it's great for the heart to regrow new
heart cells so it's very protective
against the immune system as well so
what we'll do it'll take defective
damaged parts push it into the garbage
disposal and intracellular pathogens
like microbes and fungus and yeast and
viruses and all sorts of things and it's
going to recycle that in this powerful
lysosome and then we have something
called Mis folded proteins now what does
that mean
well in your body you have all these
structural parts you have different
parts of the cell and they're all
different types of combinations of
proteins they basically have different
shapes so when these proteins are not
shaped correctly that would be called a
Mis folded protein okay and those build
up they accumulate and they develop into
this bigger piece of protein called
amyloid okay amyloid deposits are what
you see in the brain of an Alzheimer's
patient Parkinson's
a lot of times you see it in diabetics
with the arteries cataracts there's a
whole bunch of diseases called amyloid
diseases in which this kind of plaquing
or protein packing plugs up the body
okay and those are basically just the
accumulation of Mis folded proteins and
these proteins can be very very toxic
okay so your cells can take these
recycle them into new raw material that
can then be used for rebuilding so the
question is what would cause an
accumulation of these misfolded proteins
which would be damage to the
mitochondria coming from high levels of
oxidative stress usually from high
insulin okay and I've done videos on
this before we talked about the
connection between insulin resistance
which is high insulin or high insulin
and Alzheimer's and Parkinson's well
this is why because of these proteins
that get shaped incorrectly and they
plug up the whole system so you can see
there's some major benefits for a Tata G
you have neural protection for your
brain and nervous system regrowing the
brain cells cardioprotective for the
heart you have immune protection it's
anti aging and the list goes on and on
and on and of course the biggest thing
that will trigger the most potent thing
that triggers that ah the G is fasting
and in a minute fasting okay
another reason why you need to start
doing in a minute fasting it's the most
powerful thing because it corrects
instant resistance it keeps insulin down
and they'll start to trigger this
survival mechanism it's contra to it if
you would think if you're not eating or
your fasting you're going to starve and
deplete your body but it goes in a
reverse it goes into this protect mode
and enhances your survival very contour
intuitive taking all this damaged stuff
putting you through the recycler coming
out with fresh new material that can be
used for regrowing tissue alright thanks
for watching
hey if you haven't already subscribed
press the button below and I will keep
you in the know
hey that runs